back in the old days they never looked
at the like economy as something that
they needed to pay attention to like
every day we're looking at the economies
going up are we in recession is going
down in the old days they didn't have to
do that because it was just like you and
your farm and the weather and like
hopefully it all went well but now we
are all connected like what happens in
the on the other side of the world
affects you and me like we are all
connected and that's really cool because
it means we're all like organized and we
can work together to make better stuff
and everyone prospers but what it also
means is that your destiny is actually
determined by like a bunch of other
people's feelings about whether things
are looking good or bad
and that's kind of nuts
that's why these mysterious economic
Cycles happen is because no one's really
in control it's just all of us trying to
coordinate sometimes it goes well
sometimes it doesn't